el tema del desfile navideño de huacaya
de este año era confort y alegría pero
la celebración acabó en tragedia cuando
un todoterreno se abalanzó sobre la
multitud
dejando muertos y más de 40 heridos
weeks hoy hemos vivido una tragedia
horrible y sin sentido estuvo en el
desfile al principio vi a los niños
felices sentados en las aceras todavía
puedo ver las caras sonrientes un
desfile es una celebración para nuestra
comunidad en nuestra comunidad se ha
enfrentado al horror y a la tragedia en
lo que debería haber sido una
celebración comunitaria
las autoridades dicen que el vehículo
rompió las vallas de seguridad justo
después de las cuatro y media de la
tarde del domingo en un intento por
detenerlo la policía disparó contra él
mientras la policía asegura haber
detenido a una persona la comunidad ha
quedado conmocionada por el incidente
corrí a la ventana y vi caos absoluto y
gritos inmediatamente corría hacia abajo
fuera de mi apartamento y pude ver a los
niños tirados en la calle la gente
poniendo mantas sobre ellos los niños
gritando en las aceras y sin saber
realmente qué había pasado
este fue el desfile número 58 de navidad
de agua que ya el año pasado la
celebración se canceló debido a la
pandemia ahora la ciudad tiene que hacer
frente a un suceso mortal y la policía
anunció que las escuelas no abrieran
este lunes mientras la investigación
continúa las carreteras cercanas a la
escena del crimen también permanecerán
cerradas